Tuesday 18 Republican House members
nominated Trump for the Nobel Prize
crediting his peace through strength
policies so should Trump share the award
if indeed he wins we hear about Kim Chi
and moon but what about the worm Dennis
Rodman who claims kim jong hoon didn't
understand trump until Robin gave him
the art of the deal laughs last year
that book led to a change of heart I
think that this impression about Donald
Trump and an American people operating
he's had a change of heart
so now Trump's gonna meet with Kim and
maybe American hostages might be
released this is pretty amazing news so
we went to see an N in MSNBC for a
response they just hate any good news
about Trump so Robin maybe the Obama
administration's most successful
diplomat
makes you wonder should Obama have sent
Peyton Manning to talk to Putin a rod to
China Johnny Manziel to Tehran the point
is anything could have worked as long as
they had a copy of that book they all
would have done better than Hillary and
Samantha power ask those three hostages
who's a better negotiator Obama and
Hillary or Trump in Rodman now we all
know I have as much chance of winning
that award as Trump does the Euro elites
are no different than our elites they
find Trump too unseemly to ever elevate
in any way but that's the point the
exact qualities that turn off lars in
oslo or what snagged Kim Kim understands
a guy who negotiates through power not
platitudes and legacy building no matter
what Trump and Rodman have gotten us
further with this nuclear threat than
all the Beltway babblers and eunuchs out
there maybe they should read the book
too all right Dana you were at this
table when I called Dennis Rodman a
little B word yeah because he went to
North Korea so I am my Maricopa I think
I was wrong and I
apologize rob me these American hero
reserve your judgment I do wonder how
John Kerry escaped the monologue he
moves very slow I all know what he did
he blended into the wooden background
and I didn't see America was happy
because James Taylor was not in the
country for a few days
played a song yes I do think that if if
in the long run we actually do find a
peaceful solution here which there's a
long way to go from here to there then
of course then president Trump should be
granted rewarded excuse me the Nobel
Peace Prize I also think that one of the
big things and the reason I don't think
dennis rodman deserves so much credit is
that the strategic plan to squeeze China
and to get China to get little rocket
man to do the right thing is the
brilliance of this whole plan and who
started that Kimberly a man named Donald
Trump the art of the deal a book I
didn't read so if we're following this
train of thought
amazing peace and world to go to Dennis
Rodman that's with a book yes was able
all you need to change the mindset of
Kim jong-un yes making him totally sane
and open to the charms of POTUS and then
he therefore said you know what I'm
gonna stop being a bad actor yes I am
going to get it together and I'm gonna
shake hands and work with South Korea
and I'm gonna release hostages and I'm
gonna start when I stop running around
being a rocket man so I was thinking
whan that you didn't go to Iran with my
book Gutfeld Bond allots that was and I
think that would solve everything it's a
win-win either way either way
anything for great something one gets
trapped over there Jessie my seal
[Laughter]
remember that so well I just I'm just
struck by Dennis Rodman I just think
that's wonderful you have fun yeah but I
think you're having fun and I think that
oh he's serious serious Kimberly I mean
come on it so he took a book and it
changed everything I mean you know it
could be reading wait we talked about
can change your life but what happened
between the book and now he actually got
nuclear weapons well that's the art of
the deal negotiation way to couch that
[Laughter]
Donald Trump and Dennis Rodman with the
support of Kanye West yes we're ending
the Korean War I would have dropped
death Kushner out of the Middle East
they send Rodman exactly then maybe they
can share the Peace Prize those two and
I think everything is happening for a
reason what do you know what do you
think that I mean it's the serious point
here of the imminent release of these
hostages what does that mean really I
think it means a couple of things that
Mike Pompeo when he was there and he
actually met with Kim jong-un it was
part of the probably a condition yeah
and also john bolton the new national
security adviser it's like we're not
going to remember Bergdahl yes and a
trade yes really good trade right that's
not going to happen
yeah in this administration and so there
is no possible way that President Trump
would be willing to meet with somebody
who was holding Americans hostage in a
labor camp so in order to make that
happen they have to be released two of
them have been taken hostage in 2017 one
before that I think a 15 hopefully they
can apparently they're at a hotel now
they've been moved from the camp to a
hotel and that when we meet them I
actually think it's been going to be
very interesting to probably take years
for us to actually get all the
information but
and what we might learn from them yeah
about how kim jeong-hoon actually works
and so i I do want to tap the brakes on
this idea that kim jeong-hoon should
share in a Nobel Peace Prize well you
know what's interesting to me is we've
had releases before Dana we had releases
with in own I think Bill Clinton and ten
with Jimmy Carter and so this is what
the people at state and others say you
know this is part of his behavior this
is how he plays the game and he makes
offers and it's not clear what our
strategy is going in
I like our strategy I see some people
want to know whenever I really could you
know one be right